♪ (MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
When did they approach you?
Did it take long...
or did you open your legs
on the first date?
No, they took a f-- fair time
to persuade me to, uh...
LOGAN ROY: Betray me?
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
-Yeah.
-Well, that's nice.
♪ (MUSIC RESUMES) ♪
-Dead man walkin'.
-Hey.
-He's like an old, beaten dog.
You realize how fucked
you're gonna be
as soon as you're no longer
any use to him, right?
You look like shit, by the way.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
LOGAN: We need to stick tight.
Tighter than ever now.
How did he get at you?
Dad sees everything.
We just have to follow
where he goes.
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
You have a hard time
finding a happy medium between
worshipping him
and wanting to kill him.
♪ (MUSIC RESUMES) ♪
♪ (MUSIC FADES) ♪